and let me first congratulate you for
having and being able to chair this and
prepare this informal council in a very
very good way I think we had very good
discussions today and it was fruitful
exchange of views on concrete issues and
I think that would occur every topics
and I think this was was very good and I
was also very happy to be here on your
first ever presidency it's not my first
time during a presidency have already
been a few weeks ago but it's always
very nice to come true to Croatia and
Anto to Zagreb so as the damage is
mentioned today we focused quite much on
security and I had opportunity to
outline some priorities in security we
will improve EU policy cooperation
police cooperation and information
exchange by modernizing the law
enforcement cooperation framework and
simplify their operational cooperation
among member states and I am preparing
to reinforce the Mandate of Europe all
we also need to protect cities and
people against terrorists and I am
therefore preparing a proposal
protecting critical infrastructure such
as energy transport finance and health
we need to much better fight organized
crime they are according to Europe all
more than 5000 organized criminal groups
currently under investigation in
European Union and these organized crime
groups generate 110 billion euros at
least in profits in the European Union
and only 1% of these proceeds are
confiscated that's why I am preparing
proposals on freezing and recovering as
that's drugs or a threat of course to
individuals of families but it's drugs
is also a cash cow for organized crime
we are seeing more drugs cheaper drugs
and more potent drugs entering Europe
and being produced in Europe and we need
to coordinate our response and I'm
therefore preparing a new EU agenda on
drugs
we will also step up on our efforts to
combat firearms trafficking because
illegal weapons few will organized crime
and give terrorists the means for
carrying out attacks even worse than
trafficking firearms is trafficking of
human beings maybe it the most
evil evil of all organized crimes is
like a modern slavery slavery and
there's also an area where we are
preparing new proposals I must also say
that we need to follow the digital
developments crime and jeremy's have
moved online since long but they are
developing their use of the new tools
very fast law enforcement cannot afford
to stay behind so we need to take new
steps to protect children against online
abuse sharing information and connecting
information system is key and our
European agency EU Lisa plays a crucial
role to do that and we have two pending
files that are now in the trial log with
Parliament that is related to this both
to take down terrorists content online
and also to use the e evidence and these
are our important responsibilities now
for the Croatia impression the
presidency of a devil and of course I
will facilitate as as far as as possible
so that we can come to conclusions these
are some of the things that we mentioned
and exactly directive or mentioned we
are now reaching out to all Member
States to prepare for the new packet or
migration and asylum I have so
or have concrete dialogues with 15-hour
member states and all the others are
already scheduled so they're going to be
finalized in the coming weeks and I can
tell you so much that I'm meeting a very
I'm facing a constructive approach from
member states even though of course they
have very different geographical
realities and very different positions
as starting points but I'm quite
positive that we will be able to present
a new pact that will be if not a
welcomed so accepted by the member state
thank you the volumes